les travaux au bord des routes à
vélizy-villacoublay vont durer encore
quelques mois il s'agit du chantier
d'installation de la géothermie
cette énergie décarbonée va fournir de
l'eau chaude sanitaire et du chauffage
urbain 9000 foyers et 20 % des
entreprises bélizienne une bonne
solution pour la municipalité
si on faisait rien simplement avec
l'augmentation des taxes et si on
trouvait pas de solution pour basculer
sur une nouvelle énergie dans les cinq
ans le prix du chauffage urbain a doublé
donc là il y avait notre volonté de
protéger participer à la protection de
notre planète
et puis en plus avec une solution
vertueuse au niveau du porte-monnaie de
chaque division
la géothermie consiste à aller
recueillir la chaleur enfouis sous le
sol
ici à vélizy la technique de forage est
une première en europe
elle va alimenter le réseau de chaleur
de la ville à 66 % d'énergies
renouvelables notamment grâce à une
avancée technologique
celui ci a une particularité en dehors
d'être effectivement grand dans sa
taille c'est que il y à une innovation
qui était bien en une émulation que l'on
appelle multi drain c'est à dire qu'au
bout de mon forage g3 drain en fait
qu'ils sont au niveau de ce qu'on
appelle le dogger à 1500 mètres en
dessous de 2 de la surface où nous
sommes actuellement et sedrun là vont
aller capter de la meilleure manière
l'énergie géothermale de manière à
pouvoir être certain de récupérer assez
d'énergie et la fournir sur le réseau en
ce moment c'est le bâtiment
d'exploitation qui est en cours de
construction les travaux devraient finir
en novembre prochain pour une mise en
service dans les foyers en décembre 2021